[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
merci merci beaucoup tout d'abord
j'aimerais remercier alain terzian et
toute l'académie des césars m'a confié
la 38e cérémonie
je suis très heureux merci infiniment
le cinéma
c'est tard si singulier qui permet à la
france de rayonner à travers le monde
c'est avant tout des comédiens qui se
met à nu c'est le discours guillaume
canet revient en dernier ressort
tu as en toi je vais improviser par la
gueule tagueurs respecte ma présidence
madame la ministre que les
dédommagements ça
respectons - cousty d'ailleurs à ce
propos je voudrais remercier gérard
lanvin sans qui je serai pas aussi bien
décoré ce soir c'est la classe en
ouvrant ses portes le cinéma français
m'a permis de vivre des moments
exceptionnels
gd clos pateras construira pas les ans
l'egypte c'est pour céder naziste
jusqu'en alsace et courent vite ces
bâtards
avec un achat on a libéré le marsupilami
en palombie et ce soir je suis le
président de la 38e cérémonie des césars
sommaire au mike goss ça fait plaisir
mais je ne suis pas dupe je sais que si
on m'a confié cette lourde tâche ce soir
c'est pas uniquement parce que je suis
jovial espiègle est exceptionnel parce
que l'heure est grave
mesdames messieurs effectivement mon
prédécesseur guillaume canet a laissé le
cinéma français dans un état pitoyable
une croissance en berne un taux de
chômage inégalé et une ambiance tout
pour it
je ne vous félicite pas monsieur canet
mais mais halliche
j'irai jusqu'au bout de ma mission je ne
serai pas le président d'un tiroir de
cette érosion pendant mon année là c'est
un quinquennat de 1 mm
pendant mon année là je proposerai des
solutions concrètes pour améliorer notre
quotidien à tous je laisserai personne
sur le bord de la route
- président des césars
moi président des césars ce serai le
président de tous les nommer et surtout
de tous les panneaux mais comme le
marsupilami
ça se sent ça m'a énervé mois président
des césars
je ne serai pas le président des remakes
des suites d1 d2 d3 c'est fini tout ça
c'est à l'interdire est la sortie de
camping 5 d'astérix 12 et que la vérité
si je mens 19 au 22
y'en a marre de ça un peu 10 pic lurie
un peu de créativité mois président des
césars
je créerai une nouvelle catégorie le
césar du meilleur espoir féminin et
cette année je l'attribué à charlotte
gainsbourg quelques mois juste désespoir
sa mère elle je me touche quand je dis
et je vous la désespérance comme
personne ne l'a d'abord un champ
charlotte c'est tim cook qui occupe mais
avant tout loin président des césars
je changerais la constitution article 1
à partir de ce soir le président des
césars sera élu à vie
ça tombe bien de chez moi article 2 le
président choisira personnellement et ce
pour tous les films le titre les
scénarios les acteurs et la musique qui
sera confiée exclusivement à cheb khaled
article 3 personne ne peut modifier
l'article 1 ou l'article 2
et si le président venait à mourir ou à
décéder
le pauvre on sait jamais dit jaloux il
sera immédiatement remplacé par un
membre de sa famille et pour m'aider
dans cette tâche
j'ai décidé mesdames messieurs de nommer
le premier gouvernement du cinéma
français au ministère de la justice
samy naceri c'est mon ami
au ministère des affaires étrangères et
du tourisme gérard depardieu
au ministère des finances et de l'argent
vincent maraval
en binôme en binôme avec thomas langmann
comme ça on est sûr qu on est sûr que
c'est la merde tu vois
au ministère du travail et de l'emploi
monsieur jérôme seydoux monseigneur et à
la défense basile boli
le conseil des ministres se réunira tous
les premiers samedis du mois à 23 heures
chez jean pierre bacri je déclare
ouverte la 38e et dernière cérémonie
libre des césar
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]